welcome back to Facebook nonsense to
Jeremy Bowen is still with me Donald
Trump is notorious for his Whoppers we
just established but the Godfather
misinformation really resides in the
Kremlin speaking in a Bare Bones
military parade in Moscow this week's
supposedly to celebrate Victory
featuring one solitary tank Vladimir
Putin accused the west of unleashing War
on Russia of course the opposite is true
and the war that he began expecting
victory over Ukraine in just days has
been a disaster for his country Russia's
military is beset by infighting the head
of Putin's Wagner mercenary group is
brazenly questioning his dictator
what will the country do our children
grandchildren who are the future of
Russia and how can we win this war if by
chance and I'm just speculating here
it turns out that this grandfather is a
complete [__]
extraordinary broadside there against
Vladimir Putin well today the UK
confirmed descent long-range cruise
missiles to Ukraine As It prepares a
massive counter-offensive so is Putin
losing the war and his grip on power I'm
joined by evgeny Popoff an MP for
Putin's United Russia party and host of
the Russian 60 Minutes political news
program thank you very much indeed for
joining me why is Russia losing this war
let me correct you Pearson thank you for
giving me your flow I'm not a member of
any party in Russia I am in a faction of
uh parliamentary
um in Russian Duma of United Russia and
of course I mean Putin especially right
now Russia is not losing the war of
course we can see your plans to offense
to make an offense to our territory to
our troops to uh some um Russian cities
inside my country but we gonna fight for
our security grantees for Russian people
on donbass because uh you told a lot of
stories today but you didn't tell the
main story uh seven people have been
injured in hotlifka in donbas one people
was killed by bringing bomb in Donetsk
today many people have been injured in
Hearthstone territory but you only see
and you only cover one side
hang on hang on let me let me stop you
there the real story if you want the
real story is that Russia illegally
invaded Ukraine a democratic sovereign
country which is now a democracy
illegally invaded it over a year ago
assumed it would just run it over in a
few days met extraordinary resistance
from the Ukrainian people and I spent
the next year in a bit and committing
acts war crimes acts of utter barbarism
against Ukrainian people deliberately
targeting civilians targeting maternity
hospitals shelling people in streets
committing mass murder all over Ukraine
that's that's the real story
that's real story for you because you
live in the myths uh the appears because
I I thought you were a reporter and
journalist because we used to live in
New York at the same time and I uh well
remember you on CNN and you've been
great journalist great interviewer but
let me ask you let me answer your
questions if you're talking to me about
real situation but uh
uh I can tell you about real situation
um how about Georgia yesterday we
elicit ban on direct flights between
Georgia and Russia what was the United
States response they told bilisi the
real democratic government of uh
sovereign country that they can't fly to
Russia Georgians can fly to Russia we
canceled Visa Visa regime with Georgia
what uh the United States told us not
number one with respect with respect
you're not talking about what I just
explained to you is the real story why
did why did Russia illegally invade
Ukraine why is Russia committing endless
war crimes in Ukraine why is Russia
kidnapping tens of thousands of
Ukrainian children and taking them out
of the country
why are you why are you as a country
free doing all these things why is
Vladimir Putin behaving like a Brazen
dictator who thinks he can just seize
countries and kill anyone that gets in
his way that they're the questions I
want you to answer do you have any
answer question you want me to respond
first
why did you illegally invade Ukraine we
didn't wait Ukraine I can tell you a
long story don't bother with a long
story you did you clearly invaded
Ukraine types of Ukrainian government I
can tell you um a lot of stories which I
uh been seen by my own eyes from donbas
how Ukrainian Army uh uh still killing
many Russians on dunbar's territory the
Ukrainian people the Ukrainian people
led by President zielinski are defending
themselves against what has resembled on
occasion genocidal Behavior by Russia
I went to Buca for example uh in Kiev
and saw for myself the scene of the
massacre that occurred there I talked to
people who had lost relatives in that
Massacre that was a war crime and
Vladimir Putin and others involved in
this are going to be held account to it
but I simply ask you again why did
Russia illegally invade Ukraine and now
that it's been going on for nearly a
year and a half and it was supposed to
last three days when are you going to
accept this has been a total Fiasco a
disaster for Russia we saw the pathetic
scene at the Victory Parade of one tank
which presumably is all you've got left
to show off on your Victory Parade when
are you going to Stop The Killing The
Killing and the murder you're like take
your Carlson this is your mono uh it's
not a modeling I'm just telling you some
cold hard facts
this is not a fact you don't know facts
because I I have heard your questions
because uh this story have began uh many
years before our Invasion to Ukraine
you mean
you should you should study history
yeah you're legally invaded Crimea in
2014 and then you were legally invaded
Ukraine last night I'm fairly up to
speed on the history of what you've been
doing
[Music]
Crimea I've seen everything by my own
eyes you know and I can tell you about
every moment of this conflict from uh
2004 from yeah but you don't think you
don't think the Russia invaded Ukraine
therefore you're living in a totally
deluded World which doesn't exist
because obviously obviously Russia
invaded Ukraine everybody saw the whole
world saw it but you called it a special
operation I'm a special operation turned
out to be a complete disaster didn't it
and now you're losing and even the
Wagner mercenary group are calling Putin
a [__]
can I ask you yeah can I respond if you
can
of course I don't think it's funny Mr
Popoff I don't think the slaughter and
the May means thousands and thousands of
innocent civilians in Ukraine he's funny
sorry I don't have the Russia I can't
say any work I as Russian people as my
state can say a word and we can't
explain what happens because you live in
the midst you live in this Western
stereotypes you should respond uh
you should give
arrest warrants to toilet Blair to
George Bush for Iraq you should give
well for wonderful okay
okay hang on for what it's worth I led
the campaign in Britain with the Daily
Mirror newspaper against the Iraq War I
felt that well hang on let me finish I
thought that was an illegal invasion of
a sovereign country not dissimilar to
what we've been seeing in Ukraine from
Russia yeah and I'm not a I'm Not Afraid
Mr Popov to admit that I think my
country behaved illegally with that
Invasion are you prepared to admit that
your country illegally engages
[Music]
you didn't do that are you prepared to
admit your country illegally invaded
Ukraine
that's completely false uh and that's
not true okay we Mr Popoff if you can't
honestly if you're going to deny the the
obvious then we're gonna have to leave
it there I appreciate you joining me
thank you very much indeed Jeremy
this level of delusion where you can
have a a Russian politician who just
will not even admit they invaded a
country when we all watched it happen
what do we do with that well I think
from from their point of view what
they're after is the consistency of
their line they don't want leaks in the
front that they've put out and he's a
big supporter of Putin so he's echoing
what Putin says and he knows he can't
convince you so I think that
when they talk like that they're talking
to their own audience but they're also
the fact is around the world
China India yeah the global South a lot
of people are more likely to agree with
him yeah I read them somewhere I read
somewhere a third of the world has
sympathy with if not fulsome support for
what Russia has done because they look
at what the West has done and you talked
about Iraq and they've thought and they
think well where's the difference I mean
that is a yeah but I I think that's held
I would say the differences in this
country people like me on television uh
journalists were able to say freely if
we believe of that Invasion we have a
democracy and we have a free press and
over there it's an autocracy and it
comes out you know Putin sets the line
they follow it so I think all you can do
when you talk to these people is what
you do you've got to stick to your guns
and try and
um put the other case Donald Trump said
in in this uh CNN thing yesterday that
he thought he would solve the Ukraine
war in one day if he wins the wire let's
take a listen to this
put it a nicer way
if I'm president I will have that War
settled in one day 24 hours
[Applause]
Preposterous maybe what he's saying is I
will turn off the tap that keeps the
ukrainians going of money and weapons
and then they'll lose that'll settle it
and that of course would be a great
victory for Putin if that if it happened
that way how do you see it ending this
Ukraine war well I think that this is
pretty important because if someone like
Trump does if Trump himself beats Biden
and goes into the the White House then I
think the money tap will get turned off
or really really throttled back and
actually the ukrainians really need this
Western support if they're going to win
Russia has a population four times
theirs so I think that if they don't
make breakthroughs this year then it's
going to be a long long conflict